all right let's get into audience
questions for the week of course
questions submitted by you if you have
questions that you would like answered
on this segment just go to our website
david pakman.com send an email using the
contact form first one hey David
at this point what could really be so
bad about what's in Donald Trump's tax
returns that he still is fighting so
hard to prevent their release yeah this
is true I mean the guys being impeached
and there are still all sorts of
proceedings meant to hide Donald Trump's
tax returns I won't give you the full
list of the different mechanisms that
have been attempted in order to try to
obtain those tax returns so let's go
through the list from the beginning that
we speculated was the justification for
why Donald Trump didn't want his tax
returns released we'll talk about how
likely each of them is but then also
more importantly whether it would still
matter I think that the reason now Trump
wants to hide the tax returns is
different than what it was four years
ago
first we speculated maybe Donald Trump
doesn't really make nearly as much money
as he claims to and or although tax
returns wouldn't necessarily show net
worth they would suggest that the net
worth Trump claims is likely overblown
this could be a blow to Trump's ego
Trump is obsessed with status and how
he's perceived and wants to be seen as
rich and all of this stuff that's one
possibility the other possibility we
speculated about was that there would be
liabilities or entanglements exposed by
his tax returns that would be
politically difficult for Trump one was
he's in huge debt to Russia he took
money from Russia he's way more tied in
with Russia than he has admitted that
maybe at this point if that went public
I don't know that it would really be
very damaging to Trump it might be
embarrassing to some degree but the
Republican Party at this point has
completely bought hook line and sinker
the story that there's nothing wrong
with anything Trump did with Russia any
time Russia comes up it's a witch hunt
it was a hoax whatever I actually don't
think it would even be that damaging if
that was revealed but that's another
possibility for what's in Donald Trump's
taxes the other possibility is that
there will be discrepancies
made made public between Donald Trump's
private claims or claims for lending
purposes about the value of different
assets and the ones that he claims for
tax purposes so you might if you're
using a certain asset as collateral for
a loan when you apply for the loan you
claim a much higher value to make you
look like a better a lending risk to the
bank but for tax purposes
you want to minimize the value of that
asset in order to pay less in taxes that
depending on how the accounting is done
and how much of that stuff is on his
personal taxes anyway you may or may not
be able to glean that from personal
taxes in any case it would be indicative
of a crime I believe because in New York
City you're not allowed to sort of have
double books as it were where you value
assets differently for different
purposes according to one accountant I
spoke to but it sort of exceeds our
scope and again politically I think his
followers would just say that that's
smart that that's that's all that is
there's speculation that maybe some kind
of other crime would be exposed by
Donald Trump's taxes I don't buy that at
all if Donald Trump committed crimes
that are financial crimes he has his uh
professional accountants prepare taxes I
can't imagine that a professional
accountant would plainly expose that
some kind of crime has been committed
there might be something that alludes to
one that would require more research and
other documents I think at this point
the real reason Donald Trump is still
fighting this hard to hide his taxes are
either number one just because of the
income net worth thing did the extent
you could glean it because of his ego or
it's just Trump doesn't want to take the
loss image is what matters to Donald
Trump if Trump wants his taxes to be
private Trump wants to win the fight
about keeping his taxes private and
there's really nothing for him to gain
by releasing them at this point it is
only downside risk even if we agree the
risk isn't that great that his followers
would essentially justify rationalize
anything that's in the taxes it's
unlikely that there is an obvious crime
in the taxes and even if there is Trump
has been completely Teflon when it comes
to everything that he's done
that does or potentially breaks the law
I think now it's just downside risk
there's no advantage to releasing the
taxes Trump wants the win and that's
mostly what it is right now if you have
a different view let me know